hi guys it's silverette again and what
am i going to do this episode well it's
a little hard to explain that just loads
of random things that i just
decided i would do when i opened this
park in my new computer and i was like
okay now that i can do this let's just
go ahead and fix some things that i
thought were kind of wrong with this
park and something to start with would
be the terrain texturing because i
didn't really use the checkerboard
pattern yet i did use it
at some places i don't know why and how
but i did it and came up with a stupid
texture that didn't really look good so
i just decided to go with the standard
combination of asphalt and that little
nice little grass texture
so
um that's it for that and now you can
see that i'm getting rocks and all kinds
of things for the station over here and
yeah i've also been working on the
station in this episode just random
things adding little towers and stuff
like that and these trees because i
think this this was pretty much the time
though it was a little bit earlier that
i discovered that station jim's
gardening 2.5 is basically heaven for
any foliage lover since it's such an
amazing set and i used to never get it
because the download didn't work for me
for some reason but now that i've got it
i think my rollerco second three life is
never going to be the same
quite honestly it's it's just an amazing
set just really love the pieces in there
and what also made me attracted to this
set very much was the fact that it had
pines in it and we've been
well we've had loads of pine sets we've
had
um old spices pines of course all spices
all spices trees had some points and
i think that station jim's earlier
gardening sets also had some pine-ish
trees but there were never really pines
which i felt okay these have a nice
really realistic dark texture and shape
that i'd want to use and stitching jim's
gardening 2.5 does have that so i
decided to go and use that set and it
turned out to be a great choice so
that's really cool
and over here i'm just trying to add
some more details to this building
because at this point it's
kind of just a simple alpine building
but of course it does have those weird
medieval arcs and random things attached
to it but then again it's not quite as
weird and over the top as many of the
other buildings in the park so i just
decided that i would kind of mess around
and see what i could do with this
and in the end i just decided to go with
some small medieval towers and random
alpine thingies
and of course trees
because trees work really well with
buildings of course there's the um well
somewhat common tactic to
take for example you've built a building
and you've built a building i don't
really like it and you're like huh screw
this building i don't want this building
then a very easy way to kind of get rid
of it without really getting rid of the
building of course is to place trees
around it kind of blocks the view of it
but even if you have a good building uh
some trees around it can really just
make it look even better so that's what
i just decided to go for with this
alpine station because i didn't really
like it that much but i just wanted to
keep it there and see what it would look
like with some trees around it so that
type that turned out to be pretty cool
and now is the part where i do rock work
and i've actually been very delighted to
do rockwork again because weather is
fully i mean yeah it's called weber's
foliage set but nobody uses it for the
foliage honestly it's all about the
rocks but that rocks about the rocks no
treble and
yeah so since i can use that set again
i'm pretty much addicted to weber's
foliage and whether it's large rocks so
that's why i've been doing that
and then
i i'm doing so many random things at the
moment then i looked at the cost when i
was like could use some foliage so i
decided to do that
i don't know this is this is really
weird to commentate over it because the
way that i played roller coaster second
three at the time was just like oh i'm
gonna look at my park and i'm gonna do
this and then a couple of minutes later
i'm like yeah i'm going to do this now
and that's basically how i spent
a couple of hours of playing
rollercoaster second three
a lot of
well experimentation some try on the
error stuff
but it came out pretty well and at this
point i'm also doing something which
i've tried to procrastinate because of
the rock problems for a very long time
that i'm finally able to do and it's
doing the back side of the inverted
coaster it's after somebody
left a comment that he'd really like the
layouts and just the way that it goes
like through
pretty much the entire section of that
late uh part of the park honestly it's
such a huge layout and that's why i kind
of realized that yeah it is huge since
it goes on that mountain over there and
just does all kinds of high stuff over
there and then
like this is
i don't know how to explain it and then
it has that
part near the station with the stupid
helix over there don't know why i really
kept that helix in and and then you have
the part where you go to the lake and
there's so much diversity in the layout
that it's also really fun to theme this
right as long as those sets work though
of course but yeah so far i'm actually
having loads of fun theming this ride so
that's really cool
i say that too often sorry
i won't do that again
or at least i'll try not to do that
again one thing about the invert that i
still kind of need to find a way to fix
though is the fact that the last part
especially this little part around the
castle is probably way too fast
i mean it's not that fast that it would
kill people riding it but it's pretty
unrealistically fast
if unrealistically it is even a word
which it probably isn't but you get what
i mean so
yeah i kind of want to fix that i don't
want to see if i can change the layout
in some way that i can add a break
somewhere and slow it down just a bit
though that would mean that i need to
add an extra lift hill at the end but i
think that's worth it
it's probably better to keep a good
pacing throughout the ride than having a
stupid well fast coaster but not having
an ugly lifter at the end
so
yeah that's pretty much my thoughts on
that
and that's why i realized i need to
finish this part
and honestly when it comes to this part
of course i'm doing the supports right
now but i was pretty much doing the
support because i had no idea how to
actually theme this little part there
are usually parts where i usually really
have a great idea of whether i want to
build a forest or whether i want to
leave it bare but with this little part
next to the path over there i just have
no clue what i want to do with that so
i'm still leaving that bear up until
this moment and even though i've worked
on so many things throughout the park i
still haven't really tackled that little
spot over there
i don't know if that's a great idea but
yeah i'm kind of procrastinating that
for the moment
and that's why i tried adding something
in the middle of the helix but
i just couldn't find anything and of
course there's that giant tree but
that's way too big it's gonna dwarf all
of the buildings and i don't quite want
that
one of the things that make these
buildings look nice is the fact that
they're just about the same height as
the trees are and you don't want your
trees dwarfing your buildings at least
as long as you don't want small
buildings of course you can
place large trees if you have
such small buildings that it doesn't
really matter either way or you're
planning to do it oh and there was a
time skip over there because i decided
to remove the spire on top of the hill
over there and place the silverettes
alpine um alpine something i don't even
know this i don't even know the name of
my own set anymore what is it ah okay i
forgot but i decided to place the spire
over there so that is that
and
though i had to kind of get used to it
in the beginning i feel like it does
look better right now
i don't know why it it also looks more
alpine-ish in a sense
and that's why i started working
on um oh god am i gonna pronounce it
again no
on on the free fly coasters layout um
well scenery
yeah
and more specifically foliage
because
i just wanted to add a heap load of
foliage to this little ride and see what
it would look like then of course it
does kind of take away the kind of
village theme that i had going that does
of course
uh that is of course related to attack
on titan and the 3d minerva gear and all
that
but then again foliage is always a very
nice little detail and i just decided to
go for it and i think it's gonna i think
i'm gonna keep it
looks pretty cool
and yeah as you can see loads of bushes
loads of flowers at some point i started
adding many flowers at some point and
just couldn't stop doing that because i
love it sometimes
and in the end
i think it does make the ride a lot
better
at first i was thinking about maybe just
placing small shrubs and stuff like that
on the rocks because i didn't want to
cover the rocks altogether
but now i feel like it might actually be
nicer to just cover the rocks but
but anyway that's this episode so thank
you for watching and see you on the next
one bye